Jimmy thank from gamespot here at e3
2016 we're here at razors booth I'm here
speaking with Louise from girl of one
and Louise can you tell us what glove
ones all about yeah
buffing is a haptic device that the less
you feel and touch everything on your
screen or through your hmd like the new
HD k2 and moreover we incorporate motion
capture technology with the newest
generation so you have a unique system
for richer reality that lets you to have
a full immersive experience right so I
just had the chance to try it for about
a couple minutes and it's you know it's
a glove that you were with haptic
feedback can you tell us you know how it
works you know what's involved with
setting it up you know is it a gyro base
is the camera based or for the haptic
feedback we have an array of Biber
tactile actuators we have Tang in the
pan so they are able to vibrate in
different vibration profiles up to 1024
independent so we can recreate very and
reach touch sensations for your brain we
are ultra low latency and this is very
important for your brain to translate
the correct touch sensations and for the
tracking we are able to have full upper
body forearm hand and full finger
tracking uses I am use with no drift
this is our main most important
technology we have no drift with djaro
is there enough accuracy though in terms
of thing I noticed that when I tried it
I think my virtual arm was slightly to
the left of where my real arm is this is
because the initial calibration maybe
was not perfectly done so this is the
only matter about this if you calibrate
slowly with time enough and in the
perfect position I can assure you that
you don't have any graved can you walk
us through what the calibration is like
for those who haven't tried it the
calibration right now we are using is a
post based so starting from that from an
initial point we have appropriate
proprietary algorithms running inside to
have the full motion tracking but we are
we need only a pose and starting from
that with no external tracking points or
reference or systems we are able to
provide full finger tracking the upper
body cool you know like one of the
things that I saw in the demo was there
was you know like a rocket
last a fire and I could put my hand
underneath and I could feel like the
fire like shooting back at my fingertips
and that felt really good
my bigger question is like how are you
gonna get this incorporated into into
games what are you guys doing there
actually it's pretty easy because we are
over top layer above the camera games
but moreover we are trying to develop a
compatibility layer to those games that
you don't want to modify the good source
code analyzing the events of current
current games adding a basic layer
compatibility with haptics so you have
two ways to integrate the haptics on top
of your game or you run a very basic
compatibility layer but what about just
like the pure you know just your
movements and getting your hands in
there isn't that gonna be a lot of work
actually this is transparent I mean this
is everything transparent for the
developer the developer only has to - to
worry about the haptics in the object he
wants to be interactive or otherwise I
hacked the physics engine I just meant
like getting your hands in the game
though like one games have to like be
programmed to you know work with the
gloves or drag-and-drop
our prefabs we are C++ C sharp unity 5
and Unreal Engine ready so it's pretty
Z's just drop drag and drop and you have
your hand model with all the tracking
all the haptics basic haptics and if you
want to design your haptics we have a
visual sensation designer so you can
paint your your your haptic sensations
and they are well they are going to be
reproduce while you are interacting with
these objects it's pretty easy cause and
when I tried on the glove you know had
full finger tracking and tracked my arms
I don't notice that when you set it up
you kind of strapped it up to my my arm
and like almost uh you know around the
chest as well are you guys tracking more
than just the hands in the arms is it
the upper body where you guys do you
know legs eventually what's the goal
there this is only the starting point I
mean you may know other solutions are
using the bike controllers to provide
this basic tracking but with our
technology we can extend to the whole
body and this is a just a beginning
point so at the moment we are we have
upper body tracking with the arm forum
hand and finger but we will extend to
the whole body
sure
oh and then my final question price and
release date for this thing well we only
have prize for glove one is around $199
but with this new generation we don't
have any price yet because this is a
prototype until this is a pre-release
product so no price for that for glove
one that it's available for purely right
at the moment or before after this event
it's going to be around $199 Oh awesome
Thank You Louise yeah for more a three
coverage stay tuned to game spot calm